[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
and welcome to part two
of this series on using Google
Colab to code, train, and test
neural networks in the browser
without needing to install
any kind of a runtime.
In the previous video, Jake
introduced you to Colab
and how you can get
started with it.
We'll take that to the
next level in this video,
and I'm going to show you how
to install TensorFlow into Colab
and then play with the different
versions of TensorFlow,
such as those that use the GPU.
The first thing you can do
is to create a new Colab.
Did you know that you
can do this directly
from Google Drive?
Just click New,
and you will find
Colaboratory in the More menu.
Once the Colab is
created, you'll
have a new code
cell ready for you.
You can then type
Python code into this.
But I'll create a new
code cell and, in it, I
will use the PIP command
to install TensorFlow.
PIP is a command line
tool, not a code command,
so you have to prefix it
with an exclamation mark.
That way Colab
will understand it.
When I run the install
command, the environment
will download and
install TensorFlow
if it isn't already installed.
You can then check if it worked
by printing out the installed
version.
This is done with this code.
And when I execute
this code, you
can see that we have
version 1.12 installed.
Now TensorFlow also comes
in different versions.
For example, if you want
to use a GPU for learning,
there is a GPU version.
Let's look at how to install
that in a fresh notebook.
Because the GPU
version needs a GPU,
we first need to be sure
that our runtime has a GPU.
So to do this, I find it
best to reset all runtimes
and then set the runtime
type to be a GPU-based one.
It may take a few
seconds to allocate
the new virtual machine
and then launch it.
Now I can install the
GPU flavor of TensorFlow
with pip install tensorflow-GPU.
You'll see that it isn't
present on this machine,
so it will download
and install it.
And now I can check the version
of TensorFlow as before,
and we'll see that we
also have version 1.12.
And that's it.
In the next video
in this series,
I'll take that to the
next level and show you
how to train a
neural network using
Keras to perform classification
of breast cancer data.
And I'll see you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]